is Steve Kerr with us Erfurt see sure is
he's the Warriors head coach Steve Kerr
back on the program coach how are you
today I'm good are you doing how's your
health
it's better thank you thank you for
asking but do you find that I mean I
mean it got bad what we ever understand
just how bad this was I know that
certain things are kept private but for
you to be missing games and not sure if
you'd be able to come back I mean it got
to be pretty dark I'm sure for you yeah
I mean I wouldn't wouldn't miss a game
unless it was it was bad so it's been
it's you know it's been a rough go but
I'm doing better and appreciate you
asking and let's talk some hoop how
about that okay we can do that could I
take could I take you one-on-one right
now oh no question it does it does help
your health when you look out at that
roster there but I'm curious when you
what is it that you see that's missing
with this team right now nothing I mean
you know I mean it doesn't mean we're
perfect but I don't III don't ever walk
into the gym and go man I wish we had
this or I wish we had that I would be
foolish to do something we've got an
unbelievable roster we got a bunch of
guys who are unselfish and can defend
and play two ways and this is this is a
fantastic roster did you reach out to
Dwayne Wade I talked about Myers after
doing was bought out by the Bulls Bob
called me and said he had spoken with
the Dwayne's agent but I don't think
there was ever you know anything it was
gonna happen I mean you know our team is
pretty sad and there was obviously a
great spot for him in Cleveland and so I
you know a discussion was was had I know
that that's kind of par for the course
what move in the offseason made by a
team caught your eye
well I mean the obvious ones I don't
need to mention I thought the the really
interesting one was rudy Gay to the
Spurs hmm you know I the Spurs have the
last couple years have really kind of
stayed stayed big in an era when teams
have gone smaller and you know they've
played Gasol and Aldrich together you
know Duncan before that and and they've
kind of zigged when a lot of teams have
zagged and I respect that obviously but
nobody's been more successful over the
last 20 years but I think they they
addressed that need for more versatility
on the wing and you know the league
really has become so much about guys who
can play multiple positions and and so I
think they address that with Rudy and I
think it'll be really interesting to see
how he fits and it seems like no matter
who they pick up you know that player
succeeds and does well fits into the
system so I think they're gonna they're
gonna be under the radar as usual
everyone's going to talk about OKC and
Houston and in US and in the Spurs well
when they're 60 games and nobody will
pay much attention how would you
describe the culture of the Spurs I
think you spent four years there can you
put it into words
well it's it's hard to put into words
because it's really something you have
to experience but I think there's
there's an unbelievable respect for pop
that every player feels immediately and
the reason you feel that respect is
because of who he is as a person
you know his basketball knowledge is
unquestioned and you know he's one of
the best in the game planning
strategically and all that but it's just
the feeling that you have when you go
into the gym every day you know you're
gonna work you know what you're doing
matters but you know that pop cares
about you you know he cares about your
family you know that he understands that
we're playing a game and there's a lot
bigger things going on in the world and
yet the game means everything to hit at
the same time and so it's a really
really nice mix just perspective and in
competition and and and and dedication
and and you can feel it and I think
that's one of the reasons they've been
successful for so long it just carries
over from one wave of players to the
next you Steve Kerr the warriors head
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner
how much did gregg popovich political
views affect yours well I think we we
share a lot of the same values and views
and we talk pop and I probably talk once
every couple of weeks all year long
he's one of my good friends and mentors
and I have great respect for his
conviction and especially as it relates
not to politics but as it relates to
dignity and and importance of words and
actions and and how people conduct
themselves and I think that that
transcends you know by in a partisan
politics that's for sure
your reaction when you saw that you were
part of the cover of Sports Illustrated
this week well you know I was a Sports
Illustrated junkie as a kid I could have
ever imagined that I would be on the
cover of Sports Illustrated so I was
pretty flattered but yes my as my son
told me yesterday I'll bet you'd never
thought you'd be on the cover of Sports
Illustrated with Roger Goodell and the
owner of the Jaguars and who else was on
there I can't remember who I was next to
you but it was kind of surreal you know
when I somebody sent me an email with
with a photo of the covers like wow this
is this is kind of cool but then my
immediate reaction was where the hell is
Kaepernick I mean he's the reason for
this whole social movement in sports and
he wasn't on the cover I was confused by
that
and you had Steph Curry there
Commissioner Goodell Aaron Rodgers on
there shod Khan the owner of the
Jacksonville Jaguars that the first time
you've been on the cover of Si I think I
was on one time when I was in college
like one of those you know tiny little
photos in the upper left corner you know
I may have put it up on my wall I'm not
sure who do you think is the best player
in basketball right now well I'm asking
me to be an analyst can you be an
analyst and actually look not know you
cannot know got one I'm a coach is
whatever I say is going to be used
against me can I take out your team and
ask you who's the best player or is that
still yeah okay so my team you know so
we take out your guys the best player in
basketball is okay and I would put I
would put Kauai right you know I just
think that these guys are so dominant
physically in an era when you really
have to be able to guard every position
you know those guys do it that's all the
reasons dream on is so important to us
obviously guard every spot but these
days you got a guard one through five
LeBron can do it who I can do it and
both are dynamic offensively both have
developed three-point shots I thought
what LeBron did last year I me probably
had the best season of his career when
it comes down to it he's addressed all
the weaknesses that he had early in his
career and made them strengths and he's
just gotten better and better certainly
would be nice to get you on record you
saying that Durant's better than LeBron
Steve I know that's what you're trying
to accomplish well you are I'm going to
refrain from comment you were a heady
player in your time you were read the
court always see the core did you guys
lift weights when you were playing you
couldn't tell no I couldn't tell but but
I Jordan it felt like Jordan was the
first to you know he brought in you know
Tim as his as a trainer and like a
personal trainer
I don't know if anybody else was lifting
weights back then and fast-forward to
now is that something that is you know
day to day or something that your team
is involved in I will say this that my
first team in the league 1988 I walked
into the office of the Phoenix Suns and
they handed me a membership card to a
gym across the street and they said if
you want to lift
here's your membership card fast-forward
to now what is this that was 88 so 29
years later I guess we've got about five
people who help our players in the
weight room every single day it's not so
much lifting weights although there are
weights involved it's much more about
balance and coordination and keeping
certain muscles strengthened especially
with like resistance stuff and man it
yeah bands and and and then you know
that corresponding with work on the
training table keeping their hips
aligned keeping muscles aligned so
there's been so much education over the
last 30 years you know it used to be
just going to go do some bench press and
shoulder press and and some leg lifts
and you know then you're done and now
it's there's much more of a science to
it I don't know a whole lot about it but
I watch our group and I know what
they're doing
the president's response to Steph your
reaction when you guys were disinvited
to the White House was what well we were
never invited in the first place
technically I know there was some
discussions behind the scenes but you
were disinvited I think we were just
invited before we were invited this is
kind of par for the course and you know
obviously a lot of us have been
outspoken about about Trump and on our
team myself included so it didn't it
didn't really surprise me
do you have Republicans on the roster
I don't know I've never asked any of our
players their political party I do
remember about 20 years ago when I was
with the Spurs in this great pop pop
used to divide shooting groups based on
just like random questions you know it
would be like if you're you know anybody
who you know is a Steelers fan and
whatever you know go down that that way
and everybody a fan of the cowboy down
this you know he would do stuff like
that all the time just to keep us
entertained and I remember one time he
said all right all the Republicans down
there and all democratic down at this
end we're gonna do two teams shooting
and it was you know it's like a 12 to 3
type thing so there there weren't a lot
of Republicans on that team but there
are a few and but I never asked that
question and to be perfectly honest I
have a really hard time that this is
portrayed as a partisan political issue
this to me this has nothing to do with
Democrat Republican it just has to do
with humanity it has to do with dignity
and and in words and actions a matter
doesn't matter you know what party
somebody is affiliated to it's just a
bad respect and and how you treat people
good to have you back glad you're doing
well and thanks as always for joining us
Dave we appreciate it thanks for having
me Dan take that Steve Kerr I don't him
in a game of one-on-one right now own
him
of course he can't move but I'd that's
it's still hived
and I have friends a win Danny and I say
that to a friend of mine who was so much
better than me in college but he put on
some weight now and I said I would own
you and he goes but it doesn't matter
now yeah it does
the rest of my life I'm trying to knock
off names that were so much better than
me only as good as your last game yes
Continental Tire Coach's Corner official
tire major league soccer soccer fans
expect peeper formance on the pitch also
demand peak performance on the street
that's why Continentals built a tire for
what you do whether you're headed to the
game taking the kids to practice or
going for my off-roading Tata Nano is
engineered lighted tires that includes
besting
but braking superb handling Continental
Tire proud supporter of the Dan Patrick
show visit continent tire calm the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience